- All right.
You remember peaches?
- Yeah. Peaches, man.
That was one of my first
little hearts, man.
She was one of the girls that one
of the first girls to let me know
that it was some real ones out there
that except you when you're up.
Cause she got with me, man.
I was way up running around
with a Louis Vuitton
bag with 13,000 in it,
jewelry on like 90 going North
from jewelry stores out in his state.
And she just wanted to get with me.
You know what I'm saying?
And she was with me,
man, I'm talking about
like four Stores, you
know what I'm saying?
She was with me, man.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm talking about doing it.
And you know what the thing
in the hand and everything
with me, you know what I'm saying,
when she was with me, man
lay them down,
leave them countless like a gazelle man.
I'll promise you man.
And her, her bed.
Yeah. And then I'm telling you, man
she was like, I mean, pizza,
me and pizzas was like
it was up there when we was going up.
Oh man, he start smoking dope
selling dope and swung with the old man.
And then they started going down.
I'm telling you man.
She was with me, man.
I went to jail.
She came to see me, send me money.
She was doing bad too, man.
Cause you know, she was kind of dude.
She was kinda bad without me.
You know what I'm saying?
Cause I was, you know,
but as she got better, man
because she started doing some
of the things that I told her man,
she got so good, man.
She started thinking she was a boy.
(man laughing)
She started thinking she was a boy
wearing boxers(indistinct) and stuff.
And she got a girl too, too.
You know what I'm saying?
She got a girl to you know
but we stay cool though.
We stay cool through it all man
And she something else man,
I wish I could find her now
she's from Harlem man.
She come from the thirties, man.
They called her too sweet.
Yeah. Some of them older,
older older than me.
You know what I'm saying?
She was running with them.
And then I come with my old
and she got with me
and we did the thing we
did the day for a while.
- [Interviewer] You got to get Peaches?
Yeah. Peaches man.
I gotta find her man,
her name is Gwendolyn Ray man.
Gwendolyn Ray,
this is where I stay
right now, downtown baby.
You know what I'm saying?
If you ever see this
you better come holler at your boy, man.
Cause I'll miss you like 90 going North.
We were allowed me.
- [Interviewer] You got started
with gangs at what age ?
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] You got
started with gangs at what age?
I started games like 11 years old, man.
I ran with Turkey.
That's why my name was little man.
Tookie is one Tookie
It Raymond watched
was something was he called me little man.
They wouldn't even let me join them.
You know what I'm saying?
They started a West side.
They started a Tookie
and a rain Marsha come
from East side originally
- [Interviewer] This was the
beginning of the Hoover gang.
- `The beginning of
this is beginning of Westside.
See the beginning of West
side is it's the difference
of the beginning of Hoover?
The beginning of Hoover,
I was a Westside first.
Westside underground.
They started underground .
because it was a lot of us.
It was a lot of us youngsters,
wanting to be down with the Westside.
And they started us
baby to have baby crib.
But we was kind of like
- [Interviewer] offshoots of the crib.
They had baby cribs,
but we was younger than the baby Crips.
You know what I'm saying?
And we started underground.
We started underground crib
and which was still part of the Westside.
You know what I'm saying?
But, and, and we had some older
We had some older homies too.
We had some big homies
from underground too ground too.
You know what I'm saying?
And we had some big homies
from underground too.
And cause they taught us,
you know what I'm saying?
They told us the way, you know
they taught us the way
and that's where I stay.
You know what I'm saying?
Westside, I know I've given up
ease up for sale, but steel.
- [Interviewer] And then that was
before the dry by air?
- The dry by air
was never really with that drive by air.
You know what I'm saying?
No, I was in the dry by air,
but I was never with it.
You know what I'm saying?
Drive-bys was just
something that I can't do.
Cause I, you got to know who you getting
at and you know what I'm saying?
If you want to put it to somebody
you put it to them, you
know what I'm saying?
You don't try to hit don't pack.
Cause you know, you know what I'm saying?
They gotta, they have a red rag and stuff.
You know what I'm saying?
The one time I did do
that, I didn't like it.
You know what I'm saying?
I didn't like it.
And I got sick and
everything, you know, it just
it just wasn't right.
Because I didn't know
who I was getting at.
You know what I'm saying?
That color.
I wasn't, you know, you know, it's just a
bunch of them and a bunch of us,
and I had one and no
they had some and you
know, we did the thing
you know, in Inglewood,
you know what I'm saying?
Which was really they side
the red side, you know
we did the thing,
I really wasn't one for
the drive-bys and stuff.
Just popping at people because
you know what I'm saying?
Like there they going, I
don't know who they are.
You know what I'm saying?
You know what?
They got color.
So, no, I wanna know,
you know what I'm saying?
I don't want to say, you know who I got
And I got, so I can't, huh?
(mummers)
Over 20 years, man,
I've done a gang of prison time, man.
I started off why I started
off central juvenile
hall, loss of adrenals.
You know what I'm saying?
I started off that way
and, and kept going.
I was in placements and stuff.
You know what I'm saying?
My parents, my, my grandma raised me
and she didn't know what to do
and what to do with me at age 12.
You know what I'm saying?
At age 12 I'm running to the streets
at three o'clock in the morning
with people like monk, Buddha,
you know what I'm saying?
Rest in peace,
You know what I'm saying?
Westside, original starters
of Westside crib, you know
the original starter of the Westside Crib
I ran with them at age 11 and 12.
You know what I was saying?
I ran with them and that's
what we branched off of.
You know, we Westside,
but we was underground.
And then we, you know
we ran with the Baby critters,
but we was underground.
And then we turned
Hoover and neighborhood,
which is why I never was with the phone
with the Hoovers in neighborhoods.
I never was with that
really because you know, I
I ran with them at, in another gang.
You see what I'm saying?
But we split up,
I went Hoover and they went one 11.
I ain't gonna say dummy living.
I ain't go discipline.
They w they went one 11 and, and you know
stuff like the neighborhood
and stuff like that.
You know what I'm saying?
You know, I got a love.
I love in hoods.
You know, with so many hits the beginning
of the neighborhood, I got a lot of love.
- [Interviewer] It's just a street.
That'll separate one gang from everything.
- And it will be, see
cause I'm from 107, you
know what I'm saying?
I'm from one 107 Hoover
and you know what I said
we got 11 dudes, Hoover, nine dudes.
Nine-fold five of them.
- - [Interviewer]And you
happened to be born a couple
of blocks over
you'd be in a different gang.
- Right?
- You being a newbie in
another gang, or you could be
from that gang living
way to hell in Timbuktu.
Also, you know what I'm saying?
Because we got chapters
in Oklahoma, Arizona
you know what I'm saying?
You know that people that
from the land we call
we call LA the land.
You know what I'm saying?
And when you from the land,
you know what I'm saying?
Like me, I'm from the
lane, I'm born and raised
you know, general hospital,
right, right around the corner.
You know what I'm saying?
Born and raised, you know what I'm saying?
I'm from the land, but I've
been to Utah, but we all
all of us refer to LA in
California as the land.
You know what I'm saying?
Cause this is where it all started at.
And, and like I said, we branched
off and formed our hood in other States.
You know what I'm saying?
Some say even other countries,
I hadn't seen nothing
from the other countries yet,
but I, I know we there though.
I know we, there like a mother who was
- [Interviewer] Those games
would be called Cribs or Hoovers
- They would be Hoovers.
And they would be who were criminals now
you know what I'm saying?
We started off Hoover Cribs
But we had so many enemies.
You know what I'm saying?
What did he used to be saying?
(indistinct)you know what I'm saying,
We don't get along with 98% of them.
You know what I'm saying?
So we said, Hoover criminal,
you know what I'm saying?
So we got along with
who we want to, you know
now we get it on.
Who want to get it on with us?
You know what I'm saying?
You can get along with us or
you can get it on with us.
We don't care one way or another
you hurt one way or another.
- [Interviewer] And back then the gangs
were making money how
You're robbing things,
You're selling drugs
- Yeah back then I was
a jewelry stole, Rob.
- [Interviewer] The crack
was big then. Right?
- Well, crack came, you
know what I'm saying?
Crack came.
You know what I'm saying?
When crack came
cocaine was their first
powder is always been here.
You know what I'm saying?
The powder cocaine was
always here, you know?
And I was in it even
back then at a young age
you know what I'm saying?
1200, $1,400 for a house,
$350 for an eight ball.
Now you get a ball for a
hundred dollars or $80.
$80 if you'd know somebody,
you know what I'm saying?
But it's 152 people that can't
get the right connections.
Now, you know what I'm saying?
It's $150 a ball.
Which is crazy.
And I really can't make
no money in it no more
because spending 150
for two and a half grams
you have to sell pretty much microdots
and don't nobody want no
microdot they tried to get high.
They want the big days,
you know what I'm saying?
I can't afford to give them the big games.
Cause I don't have the big things.
You know what I'm saying?
Chickens. I ain't got no chickens.
I got Chicky bird.
- [Interviewer] Other than that,
- Other than that,
- [Interviewer] That
fascinating a jewelry store
story you told last time.
what's the craziest thing you've seen
in your gang life?
- In my game, like the
craziest thing I say, man
I ve seen it all.
You know what I'm saying?
I seen it all from a
to Z in the gang life.
You know what I'm saying?
Because it goes down,
you know what I'm saying?
People getting shermed up.
People get served up and
doing some simple things.
You won't believe, you
know what I'm saying?
Running down the street button,
like a locking on the locking
on the telephone poles and you
can't pull them off itself.
No, it was good.
Oh, I see.
I've seen it all.
You said no
I ain't even seen people
lose their life behind.
Oh, you know what I'm saying?
Another person under the
ampoules under the influence
under the influence,
you know, isn't books.
Now you, you can say, I know
I know I could've wrote
a book or two about it.
You can do or say just about
anything under the influence.
You know what I'm saying?
That's why their credibility
is no good in court.
If you could ever prove
it, you can never prove
like I've done that somebody
smoked an extra large amount
of cocaine and stuff.
You know what I'm saying?
And then try to say that you robbed them ,
and stuff like that when they've actually
given you the stuff
when they was under the
influence and stuff like that
and then wind up turning
the police on you later
that you robbed him and
you have the stuff because
and they call it evidence, you know,
And I'd be like, wait a minute, though
this person sold me this, or gave me this
you know what I'm saying?
And, and you know what I'm saying?
I gave them something for this.
You know what I'm saying?
And I tell him quick,
Hey, I gave him some drugs for it.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah. I gave him some money for it.
Whatever the hell I gave them,
I will tell the police quick
when he tried to take me
to jail for a robbery or something that
you know what I'm saying, I
done bought from this pool.
You know what I'm saying?
It goes down like that.
- [Interviewer] And again
life exists in prison
as well right?
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] The gang scene.
- The gang scene in prison.
Oh, the gangs in the prison
stuff and nails right now
it's really a Brown against black.
You know what I'm saying?
And white, you know what
I'm saying right now?
That's how it is
and how it got that way
against a black and Brown.
- I know, but I don't know.
I'm just going to say that the
the shot callers of the Brown had problems
with the shot callers
of the black and boom.
There it is.
And the hit the street.
Bam. We're no longer able
to be with them or kick it
with them the way we used
to, you know what I'm saying?
Because we had Mexican homies,
you know what I'm saying?
That was so down.
And Mexicans gets in a blacks and Mexicans
against was so down that,
you know, it's unbelievable.
You know what I'm saying?
It's unbelievable.
You know, and it still is today
but it's just not as much as it used to be
because our racist have is a
racist define most gang lines
- [Interviewer] Which
Mexican gangs or black gangs
are more powerful
- In the pen, in the pen.
It's like running neck and neck.
You know what I'm saying?
But
- [Interviewer] On the
street, the Mexicans got it.
- On the street, The mexicans got it
Because they got the connect.
They from Mexico, you
know what I'm saying?
They got the border, you
- [Interviewer] They
ake it to another level.
- They can take to another level.
We can get with them on that level too.
You know what I'm saying?
Because we've been buying
kilos from him forever.
You know what I'm saying?
And the right black
people have so much money.
Now that it's up a tolerable,
you know what I'm saying?
It's up a tune bubble.
You know what I'm saying?
Also, you know what I'm saying?
You just can't understand it.
You know?
And I'm a case, Uzis, grenades,
you know what I'm saying?
I've had them all sticks of dynamite.
You know, I've had them,
I've had everything
you know what I'm saying?
I take nails to sticks of dynamite.
You know what I'm saying?
And stuff like that.
- [Interviewer] The stories about,
- And through them in places
- [Interviewer] The FBI or
the government or whatever
putting boxes of guns and
crack cocaine in the streets
- Hey man, it's so true.
It's so true.
But it's, it's not really
it's not really from the
real, real good side.
You know what I'm saying?
It's from the bad side of the good side
because there's bad sides and good sides
to every side is what it is.
You know what I'm saying?
That's what it is.
It's not, it's not the people.
That's way up.
That's doing it in the police.
It's the people that's down.
I figured out that, Hey
I can make a lot of
money at this right here.
And you know what I'm saying?
I'm a cop.
So when they going to do that, they really
don't want to put us in because
cops in jail get done bad.
Cops in jail get done worse
than, than a child molesters.
And we don't like child molesters.
We will kill a child molester in the joint
even though they protect
them in some States
they're so protected to some
Stacey, it makes you sick.
You know what I'm saying?
You get a hay cry for 10.
One of they is up.
But let me tell you, I tell one of you
cab lessen is up.
You hear me?
You let me know.
You mess with a kid.
You heard me, let me know.
I bet you, I don't give a
about prison or nothing else.
I get at your.
You know what I'm saying?
For messing with kids, I
will get at your for real.
And it's like that.
And the police even is with it.
Yeah. Tell us when one comes
in, Hey, he's one of those
what he don't last long on the road.
Let me tell you, and what are they doing?
Oh, beat them, rape them heavy.
All kind of all kinds of stuff to her.
They get down to how they do them kids.
Because the kids, those
people are masters.
You don't understand.
But then those people get
to see some real monsters.
You know what I'm saying?
They get done.
They get done worse than
they've ever done a kid.
You know what I'm saying?
And I'm glad to say that.
It's so true, please.
Real criminals do not like them at all.
We don't accept them as
part of us being part of us
and the protection of,
you know what I'm saying?
Criminality,
- [Interviewer] But nowadays the,
the prisons protect, put them in from 99.
- Nowadays, if you slap a
child molest or beat one up
you gonna around and get
10 years as a hate crime
because you hate a child molester.
Ain't that a?
These peoples out they rabbit
ma you know what I'm saying?
And you know what I'm saying?
They out, they rabid mind
protecting these fools.
You know what I'm saying?
But yeah, you know, it'd be some people
like us be right in there with
them and be like new hotels.
- It wasn't me.
Well, he better get the away from me.
You all say
You know, it's still get done.
But yeah, they try to make
them walk the line when it
and everything else.
But they can't, they can't
y'all they get separated
real quick.
Protective custody is what
it's called protective custody.
I think they got different names for it.
Now I haven't been to prison
in awhile and don't want to
go back you heard me
don't want to go back.
You know what I'm saying?
- [Interviewer] The most
notorious gang member
you've ever met the
- Most. Well, I've known them all.
I meant the starters of him.
You know what I'm saying?
The most.
Oh, man.
Now let me see.
Let me see.
I raised my skin Masaki and
Masa, Coty and boy Masa Cody
and my homeboy devil.
I think devil's grooving and peace.
Now. I heard, I heard
his groove in a piece.
I haven't been to the hood in a while.
Cause I'm down here.
Y'all downtown right now, but
I haven't been to the hood
but you know, word gets back.
You know what I'm saying?
That was homeys.
Leave us.
You know what I'm saying?
Go to a better place.
Cause we all know it's a
better place than this.
You know what I'm saying?
And I ain't scared to get there myself.
Send me
- If you can't
- If you can't send me little
man, Sam who would clean
but yeah, for real though,
for you don't know.
Cause we hard to find,
we hard to buy trust.
We ain't hard.
I'm down here.
- Well, yeah.
(man laughing)